definition of success and this ends the
series yeah this the final chapter um
how many is it four or five albums it's
four yeah this is the fourth the four
yeah well the fourth definition oh so
this is the fourth definition yeah but
like probably like the six or seven
project since I you know what I mean
since yeah yeah uh we got J Stone in the
building man welcome yeah man I'm in
here man what's up K welcome back man
man come on man welcome back it's a new
plaque I yeah we got a new spot man we
in here um hey so talk to me like for
you why was it time to kind of like put
a a bow on the series CU you're kind of
known for the definition series like
it's something that kind of started nip
gave you the original idea facts um why
why put a bow on it why was it time um I
just felt like you know this is the time
you know point of time in my life you
feel me where I'm on some different [__]
bro I ain't thinking the same my lyrics
ain't the same you feel me like I'm on
some success [__] bro this is this is
the time now you feel me like so that's
just where I'm on um I somehow feel like
when we talk about La rap you're always
overlooked yeah man when they mention La
rap man they need to mention me more you
feel me I feel like they don't and and
and I always tell this to people like
you've done such a great job of like
uh like kind of just flying under the
radar becoming a millionaire off of a
independent catalog like doing [__] that
most rappers can't do yeah dropping when
you want yeah and I'm you know I'm good
with that you feel me like I don't
really need I don't really need like
props from the majors or none of that
because I'm solidified already you feel
me like real [__] [__] with me
you know what I mean like the real Cat
in the industry [__] with me bro like so
at the end of the day it's like I ain't
really looking for no validation but at
the same time it's like don't forget
about me I'm over here running these
crazy laps you feel me yeah and you
you're like a um very much like you know
um at this point man like in LA Hip Hop
you're you're a figure man yeah man
don't count me out count me in for sure
like add that up y'all did the wrong
total add that up burnt money don't work
over here man count that over you feel
me I was going to say for you was there
ever any um opportunities that came up
that passed on or that you didn't decide
to go with when it comes to like maybe
taking a direction or step in the
direction of being more on a major
situation or a bigger distribution
situation yeah damn near um you know I
didn't sat I didn't sat with labels bro
I didn't sat with uh I sat with Rock
Nation you know what I mean I sat down
with rap a
lot out to rap a lot to yeah for sure
shout out to Trey you know what I mean
shout out to Jay Prince I sat down we
had a conversation we talked about the
vision you feel feel me and he asked me
like what I wanted to do he was ready to
do everything that I wanted to do you
feel me but like whoever kind of was
like middleman in the situation I don't
think he knew like that they was you
know talking the way that they was
talking cuz I had a conversation with J
Prince so that wasn't the conversation
we had when I talked to the you know the
middleman and all that you feel me so it
was just something different you feel me
so I just chose to stay independent you
know what I mean until I can holler at
the bar man you feel me myself on the
boss man CHP yeah no I mean that I think
that's cuz what you are you doing to
core drro kid how you putting out your
[__] right now man I'm strictly
independent man it's 258 no breaks man
no but you got to obviously you got to
get the music out of course so like what
service do you use I don't use no
service I am the service man so you
don't have it I'm putting my [__] out
man so you're putting your [__] directly
on the dsps yeah oh okay that's great
nah I ain't doing it myself but you know
I don't want to give away the well cuz
like a lot cuz like you know for people
who don't know there's like dist in ton
Corp which in my opinion make it very
easy to be independent n for sure let me
not pay producers you features shout out
to toon Corp though shout out to to core
I've been rocking with them since day
one all you're still fully independent
all you're doing is paying them a one
time fee yeah and giving and giving
everybody what they entitled to you can
do splits right exactly you can do that
now yeah because that's the one thing is
like when you're an independent artist
I'm sure it can get really really like
yeah it overwhelming to make sure produc
get Tak care producers got to get taken
care of the Writ compos anybody that had
anything to do let me break you off
here's your points yeah for sure yeah
but you know but that's what the majors
don't do you know I me yeah they rather
they rather they rather buy your
percentages out they give you a nice
check well and they'd rather like dick
you around as if you're a writer or a
producer there's a reason why you can
get the same you can get the percentages
but not get the money on and it takes
forever yeah you know I just saw
internet money uh the dude who runs
internet money was saying like I'm going
to start calling some of these major
labels out cuz you guys over a year
passed du on some of my producers like
fees like it's like these yeah after a
while you look around and you be like
man the numbers don't add up some ain't
adding up the numbers ain't adding up
you feel me but like when you when you
don't see that dashboard when you really
don't see the actual numbers and where
they going you know they say numbers
don't lie that's a lie numbers lie too
for you do you notice like um cuz I
always try to look at you know I talk to
about this a little bit but he's like
look now that I'm independent and I'm
off Rock Nation he's been leveling up
because he could drop whenever he wants
and he was like now when I drop it's
almost like the stock market like I put
some new [__] out and everything else
spikes up like the rest of my catalog
goes up yeah so that's the beauty of it
just keep on being consistent you can't
just drop a project and then wait two
three years and drop another project
like 100% that's why I really didn't
want to tell nobody cuz you know
[__] be you know watching how I
do my little
yeah you feel me but I ain't going to
lie as soon as a bar drop I drop January
1st I'm dropping the project February
14th I'm dropping another project March
whenever I'm dropping another project
like right you've been on it bro I'm
dropping 12 albums next year bro so next
year 12 I'm 12 albums one each month how
much music right now are you sitting
on uh unlimited bro I can't even really
imagine how much music I got cuz I still
got old stuff from me and nip we did
back in the day in 2006 and Beyond you
feel me what do you do like do you like
what do you do with that with those
records uh do we just do you just keep
them is there a time and a place always
had conversations about just you know
running the music up first running up
what we got now and then you know just
built that catalog and then like
introduce them to the old [__] but that
was when I didn't have a crazy catalog
you feel me so right yeah I got a crazy
catalog now so we can kind of like bring
up them old
uh Myspace mixtapes and crazy yeah you
know what I mean a lot of that
unreleased [__] so yeah